Writer/Director Geoff Ryan on the set of
BLOOD FROM STONE - Laughlin, Nevada, USA:
So this crew is one of a kind everyone
has a very distinct personality
everyone has been an incredible joy to work
with i mean most most are people i've known
for a long time so that's made it really
special it's not just a film set it's a
i mean it's just it's like a group of great
friends hanging out and we just happen to be
making some really cool stuff we
don't have a lot of like you know
people in dedicated roles no one dedicated to
doing script no one dedicated to doing continuity
i love the vibe all the cast and crew seem to
have like a really good symbiosis together so
i feel like there's a lot of teamwork involved um
i feel like everybody's helping everybody else so
it makes the whole process of shooting
kind of effortless and easy to go through
are we rolling yeah how are you i'm michael
caradano i'm the producer for blood from stone
tonight we're at atomic liquors we are doing
our first major fight sequence we have our uh
our actors out here working out
the the details of the choreography
our director jeff ryan would like to
do all of this in one take so it's uh
it's uh it is it's just like a dance they're
choreographing the the steps the moves the
punches and uh see if we can't make this
exciting for everyone to open the movie
you can see that the way he frames stuff
there's a long shot and he conducts them
in a very theatrical way where you have this
long scene where there's no cheating there's
no cutting there's no every two seconds like in
hollywood movies like turn of the head next shot
turn into the head next shot i mean it's like
a broken puzzle this is more like a solid piece
even though of course he's going to cut it
but working with him is pleasurable because
he would allow me to to build myself throughout
the scene that's one of the biggest problem in
the movies because in the movies because you
can't get the momentum you get on the set they
wake you up hey here's your scene when you cry
you're your eyes out and you're like whoa wait
i just woke up you know but in a theater you
would build up to that well jeff does that
he allows these long scenes that was really
good that was our first solid one in my mind
i was telling people about the production i was
like it's like a six person crew they're all doing
like 10 jobs everyone's super awesome we're doing
these crazy night shoots and everyone's just being
like such team players and like making a really
cool story come to life so that's been super
exciting to see because i didn't know how big the
crew is going to be coming out here hi i'm nika
i'm one of the producers um we're just filming
one of the opening scenes for the film actually
um so we're outside of atomic blickers
and i'm making some cocaine it's been a
complicated process putting drips of water
into sugar making it clump today i want to
show you guys some of our dead bodies so right
here we have sweet leonard took me a while to
get his hair correctly um what we did actually
was we bought um a long weave of hair and then
just snipped that up and mod podged it on here so
sweet leonard you're going to have a rough night
i feel like there's a lot of teamwork involved
um i feel like everybody's helping everybody else
so it makes the whole process of shooting
kind of effortless and easy to go through
oh
it's pretty much ego free set and and but talented
and artistic people and then of course everybody
has a good sense of humor so when you combine all
these things i mean there were so many fun moments
we were here in nevada in pioneer saloon in the
boonies and i'm about to kill a bunch of folks
in a good old western bar
uh i don't know what his name is
sam the bartender or something
one two three can you do that
yeah perfect apparently i end up
leaving in a body bag which is all good action
nice i felt really good that
was the one that was a winner
yeah awesome we don't want to get into the ice
more that way a little bit more that's great
michael give me a thumbs up thumbs up yeah
michael look at the camera there she is
it's okay it's a wrap that's all we needed
you know like some directors are really
crazy about like you get the lines
perfect and he was he was obviously you have
to know the lines but he was he was like very
uh free about that he was just like if you want to
you know add something or make it more alive
then you can do that and that that really
helps a lot because it makes me kind of feel
free to live in that space and in that moment
when you make a piece of heart you're sending
it out to the world and you have no clue who
you'll get uh to hear back from i would like
actually to ask them what did you see there
what do you think it was about i feel a much
bigger sense of responsibility because there's
so many people involved that are putting so much
themselves into it nice that was the winner yes
glad we did that one for fun obviously not for a
big paycheck they're doing it because they believe
in the project they believe in what i'm trying
to accomplish with it and so that's really the
hardest part is making sure every day that i'm
delivering the best i can in all those different
areas so that all the effort that's being put
into this everyone else feels like it's worthwhile
you guys are just chit-chatting and [ __ ]
there was this general sense of like
group accomplishment that came together
it was one of those where none of us knew
if it was going to work out because we were
trying to pull off something that would normally
be you know everybody knew the constraints were
under to do that and so when we accomplished
it you could just see this general sense of
joy exhaustion accomplishment and just this group
camaraderie that made it all possible it's not an
easy road it's all consuming we'll see where this
one goes i'm hoping it's a film for everyone as
opposed to no one hopefully they liked it but
the very least i want them to walk away feeling
like they just got a very unique experience that
they haven't seen before let's do it let's do it
you